Ob glasiert, mit Schokoguss oder pur:
Lebkuchen gehören
in Deutschland zu Weihnachten
wie Tannenduft und Kerzenschein.
Das traditionelle Zentrum
dieser Köstlichkeit ist Nürnberg,
die zweitgrößte Stadt Bayerns.
Seit Jahrhunderten wird
hier Lebkuchen hergestellt.
Er gehört längst
zum kulinarischen Erbe der Stadt.
Nürnberg und Lebkuchen ist für uns eins.
Also, Lebkuchen sind Nürnberger Lebkuchen.
Ja, der Lebkuchen hier ist natürlich
schon ein Teil auch der Stadt für mich
und auch ein Teil
des Weihnachtsgefühls hier.
Und ist auch tatsächlich
hier leckerer als woanders.
Mmh, schmeckt gut!
Ingrid Petermann ist Touristenführerin
und schlüpft gerne in die alte Tracht
einer Lebküchnerin.
In der Nürnberger Altstadt boten
diese vor Jahrhunderten ihre Ware an.
Doch wieso wurde ausgerechnet Nürnberg
zur deutschen Lebkuchenhauptstadt?
Nürnberg war im Mittelpunkt
von Europa gelegen.
Vier Handelsstraßen gabʼs.
Eine kam von Venedig, deshalb hier:
Sieht aus wie die Rialtobrücke,
in Nürnberg ist es die Fleischbrücke,
zu Ehren von Venedig gebaut.
Die Gewürze aus Nordafrika, aus Zypern
kamen über diese Handelsroute
nach Nürnberg.
Und so waren die Gewürze in der Stadt.
Sieben davon hat man
in den Lebkuchen verbacken.
Am Anfang wurde der Lebkuchen in Klöstern
unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit gebacken
– nach streng geheim gehaltenem Rezept.
Durch den Übergang vom Katholizismus
zum Protestantismus
in Nürnberg als erste deutsche Stadt
bereits 1525
hat man nach und nach
die Klöster aufgelassen
und hat sie weltlichen Zwecken zugeführt.
Natürlich gabʼs dann auch
keine Mönche und Nonnen mehr,
die Lebkuchen gebacken hätten.
Und so haben sich die Geheimnisse bewahrt,
und es hat sich nach und nach
mit Irrungen und Wirrungen
der Beruf des kommerziellen
Lebküchners herausgebildet.
1643 wurde der erste erwähnt.
Damals wurde die Zunft
der Lebküchner gegründet.
Das Backhandwerk hat sich
bis heute gehalten.
Markus Döllner ist Obermeister
der Bäckerinnung Nürnberg.
Den Betrieb hat er
von seinen Eltern übernommen.
Er backt heute in fünfter Generation.
Die Basis des Lebkuchens ist immer gleich.
Einen guten Lebkuchen macht aus,
dass mindestens 25 Prozent
Mandelnüsse oder Walnüsse drin sind.
Und es dürfen höchstens 10 Prozent
Mehlerzeugnisse in der Masse sein.
Ansonsten hat jeder Lebküchner
seine ganz eigene geheime Mischung.
Zwar haben sich im Laufe der Zeit
industriell hergestellte Lebkuchen
immer mehr durchgesetzt.
Die Kleinbetriebe jedoch,
die noch handwerklich arbeiten,
liefern ganz frische Qualität.
Wenn der fertig ist, dann bricht man ihn.
Dann kann man sich die Struktur anschauen
und sieht man gleich, okay,
hier bei mir in den Lebkuchen
ist alles ziemlich grob – also gewollt.
Wir nehmen grobe Haselnüsse.
Es gibt Kollegen,
die machen das auch viel feiner.
Das sind dann die Unterschiede in Nürnberg
von den einzelnen Rezepturen.
Kann man auch mal dran riechen –
nimmt dann die Gewürze,
fruchtige, Schokolade, Aroma,
die Gewürzaromen alles auf.
Und dann kann man natürlich auch mal
dann letztendlich, zu guter Letzt,
muss man ja das schmecken.
Bereits im September geht es hier los
mit dem Lebkuchenbacken.
Im Dezember gehen bei Bäcker Döllner
täglich gut 800 Stück über die Theke.
In ganz Nürnberg werden pro Jahr
etwa 20 Millionen Lebkuchen hergestellt.
Zahlreiche werden exportiert,
hauptsächlich in die USA und nach Asien.
Ich bin stolz auf die Tradition
oder Teil der Tradition in Nürnberg zu sein.
Und auch macht mich stolz,
dass ein altes, überliefertes Familienrezept
heute noch so guten Anklang
bei den Kunden findet.
In diesem Jahr muss der weltbekannte
Nürnberger Christkindlesmarkt
coronabedingt ausfallen.
Einzelne Lebkuchenstände in der Altstadt
sorgen trotzdem für Weihnachtsstimmung.
Die Nürnberger Lebkuchen –
eine süße Tradition,
die wohl auch die nächsten Jahrhunderte
erhalten bleibt.